أجنبيًا ، توصلنا إلى اتفاق
لتمديد سقف الديون حتى أوائل
ديسمبر ونأمل أن نتمكن من
إنجاز ذلك بمجرد أن
أعطي الكلمة اليوم
لهذه الحكومة الديمقراطية الموحدة التي
تواجه مشكلة في الحكم حتى أنها لا تستطيع
تمرير مشروع قانون البنية التحتية من الحزبين
تفاوض الرئيس
ووعد رئيس مجلس النواب
بأن يمر الأسبوع الماضي
، تحتاج الأغلبية إلى التوقف عن السير أثناء النوم
نحو
أصدقائي الآخرين ، وهناك العديد من
أصدقائي موقف الجمهوريين في مجلس الشيوخ الذي
أجده ليس منافقًا فحسب
، بل خطيرًا ومخزيًا بعض الشيء على
وجه الخصوص.  بينما نحن في طريقنا للخروج
من الوباء الذي كلف أمريكا
700000 شخص حتى الآن وما زلنا
نحارب هذا الأمر ،
فإن أسواقنا هزت
مدخرات أمريكا على
المحك ، حيث يتأثر مدخراتك للشعب الأمريكي بشكل مباشر بهذه
الحيلة.
ليس من الضروري أن يكون الأمر على هذا النحو ،
يحتاج أصدقائي الجمهوريون إلى التوقف عن
لعب الروليت الروسي مع
الاقتصاد الأمريكي
إذا كان الاتحاد  ss لا تتخذ إجراءات
لرفع حد الدين
سيصل الرصيد النقدي للخزانة إلى مستوى غير
كافٍ لدفع فواتير الدولة وستتخلف
أمريكا عن السداد لأول مرة في
التاريخ وسيؤدي التقصير إلى التشكيك في
الإيمان الكامل والائتمان للولايات المتحدة في
بلدنا  من المحتمل أن نواجه
أزمة مالية تتسبب
في ارتفاع أسعار الفائدة بسرعة وتقييد الوصول
إلى الائتمان ،
وسينقضي انتعاشنا الهش
في الاتجاه المعاكس ،
فمن المحتمل أن نشهد ركودًا
ستفقد ملايين الوظائف
وسيستمر الألم في
حل الأزمة